هذا هو كلب الخدمة الخاص بي "بيلي"، فهو قادر
على إخباري قبل أن أغمي عليه مباشرةً،
ويمكنني إما وضعه في مكان آمن أو
تناول دوائي قبل أن أواجه
أي نوبة، "
بيلي" كلب مدرب تدريبًا عاليًا ولكن
تدريبه فقط  يستحق أي شيء
بسبب المزايا المذهلة التي ولد بها بنفس
المزايا التي تتمتع بها جميع الكلاب.
إذا لاحظت أن الجرو الخاص بك يتصرف بشكل
غير طبيعي عندما تكون مريضًا،
فقد يكون ذلك بسبب هذه السمات نفسها
وهم خبراء في القراءة.  لغة الجسد
إنهم يعرفون لغة جسدك، يعرفونها
حتى من عينيك، عندما
يتعرفون عليك جيدًا ويدرسونك، فأنت
كل شيء بالنسبة لهم ويمكنهم
معرفة ما إذا كان هناك خطأ ما،
فهناك روتين الكلاب، وهي
مخلوقات جادة ذات عادات  وعندما
تتغير عاداتهم، يمكن أن تنطلق الأجراس عندما يكون
هناك شيء خاطئ سواء كانت
الكلاب عاطفيًا أو جسديًا
ستلاحظ ذلك، ويمكن أن يقودهم ذلك إلى
حقيقة أن هناك شيئًا ليس صحيحًا تمامًا
هنا ودعونا لا ننسى أن الكلاب
معروفة بأنوفها تقريبًا.  يمكن لأي كلب أن
يشم شيئًا ما، وقد لا يكون ذلك
صحيحًا تمامًا، ويمكن للكلاب شم الأمراض لدى
الأشخاص، لكنها لا تعرف ما الذي
يشمه، تمتلك الكلاب ما يصل إلى 300 مليون
مستقبلات شمية، أي أكثر بحوالي 50 مرة
من البشر،
تصف الباحثة ألكسندرا هورويتز
أنف الكلاب  قوى خارقة كهذه، إذا كان
بإمكان الإنسان شم رائحة عطر في
غرفة صغيرة، فيمكن للكلب شم رائحة العطر في
ملعب مغلق وتمييز
مكوناته، وكانت أدمغتهم وأنوفهم
موصلة بالرائحة، فلديهم
عالم شمّي غني إلى حد ما.
عالمنا البصري، لذا إذا كان بإمكانك تصورنا ونحن نرى
بأعيننا، فإنهم يرون بشكل أساسي
بأنوفهم، فهذه
القدرة المذهلة هي الأكثر طلبًا من قبل
الباحثين في عالم الطب، ويرى الباحثون ما إذا كان
بإمكان الكلاب شم الإحساس الفريد
بحالات مثل السرطانات المختلفة،
ومرض باركنسون ومرض باركنسون.  الاكتئاب
ومن خلال القيام بذلك، فإننا نتطلع إلى إنشاء
تقنية يمكنها في يوم من الأيام أن تحل محل
أنوف الكلاب للكشف الطبي،
وبالطبع هناك
كلاب خدمة مدربة مثل بيلي، وهذا كل ما
يتعلق بك، كما تعلم أولئك الذين يستخدمون
إدراكهم وحاسة الشم
لمساعدة الناس  مع مجموعة واسعة من
الظروف طالما أنه معي وهو
هناك فأنا
رملي، لا داعي للقلق بشأن
أي شيء يمكنك فقط أن تقول له أن كل ما
يريد فعله هو فقط أن يجعلك سعيدًا ويجعلك
تشعر بالتحسن